main
independent advisor on ministers
interests lord guyt has resigned he also
released a brief statement
which mentioned with regret i feel that
it is right that i'm resigning from my
post as independent advisor on ministers
interests of course this has been
something that has been debated for
quite some time it did feel like it had
gone away that the prime minister
perhaps was
if not safe not in peril with this
record with this potential resignation
um and of course this uh revolves around
the story as to whether
uh the prime minister gave a sufficient
explanation um as to why or why he
hadn't uh broken uh the
ministerial code
and this has been going back and forth
and openly discussed and he then given
another response to lord guide as to why
he felt he had not broken the minnesota
code or he'd given the sufficient
explanation lord geit now resigning is a
big big moment it's a big extra amount
of pressure on the prime minister who
may well have felt that he uh did escape
this particular threat to his future and
leadership our political respondent uh
liz bates able to join me now from uh
westminster with reaction to this and uh
and and liz uh perhaps this was expected
or a possibility a few weeks ago but the
expectation of whether this would
materialize or not had had gone away
somewhat
it had and it's quite interesting uh
that we've just heard this in the last
few minutes because we heard from lord
got yesterday he was speaking in front
of a committee of mps and we didn't
really have a hint at that point that he
was thinking about stepping down
although we knew that he had been
frustrated this has really come the
combination of um something that came
out last month which was a sort of
public standoff
over
partygate lord geith is of course the
prime minister's advisor on ethics and i
think he was quite frustrated with the
prime minister over this issue of the
fixed penalty notice that he had
received over party gate and whether
that equated to a breach of the
ministerial code this is a position that
he set out in an annual report that he
released and what came across very
strongly in that report that was that
what his frustration with the prime
minister uh that as as the arbiter of
the ministerial code he hadn't explained
publicly why he thought that that fixed
penalty notice wasn't a breach of that
but as i said uh yes he appeared
yesterday in front of a committee of mps
and we didn't get any sense at that
point that he was going um to step down
even though there had been rumors
circulating around that but today
just in the last few minutes we have had
a statement uh from lord geit he says
with regret i feel that it is right the
time resigning from my post as
independent advisor on ministers
interests so clear now that after
everything that's happened he feels uh
that his uh position is untenable and
that he has had to stand down today and
uh beyond that we don't really know yet
uh what's gone on uh behind the scenes
but clearly he feels he cannot go on in
his position as the prime minister's
advisor on ethics so interesting list
because there's been so many moving
parts of course to the prime minister's
position within his own party over
recent weeks he has just survived a
confidence vote uh and as the rules
stand today that means he can't face
another confidence vote within his own
party for another 12 months this
resignation
is only really something that could put
pressure on him within those realms is
it is it not and again
if it come moments before the vote of
confidence maybe it would have swayed a
few mps votes but in the very short term
does it make an immediate impact
well that's a really interesting
question and i think what you've touched
upon there is that there is has been
frustration uh brewing for a long time
um particularly over partygate but other
issues as well within the conservative
party and there have been many moments
where it has felt like the prime
minister's position was becoming
untenable and lord guys speaking out on
this issue was one of those moments i
think i've been speaking to conservative
mps uh
all the time about how they feel about
the prime minister and as you said one
of those
one of the key
points is that the cannot now be another
confidence vote in him and a lot of
those mps that are very disillusioned in
the prime minister are feeling at the
moment that like there isn't an
opportunity to remove him even though
we still keep having moments like this
resignations and clearly people losing
confidence in the prime minister but as
i say conservative mp's feeling that at
the moment he's untouchable and even
though things like this are happening
it's still possible for him to continue
in his position